>> Bret: I DON'T USUALLY GIVE
ADVICE BUT I THINK EVERYONE
SHOULD COUNT YOUR BLESSINGS.
MY FAMILY IS TONIGHT.
MY WIFE AMY AND SONS PAUL AND
DANIELLE WENT SKIING COME OUT WE
A FANTASTIC TRIP -- A LOT OF
FUN, GORGEOUS SNOW, QUALITY
FAMILY TIMES.
FUN SKIING WITHOUT INCIDENT
WHICH IS ALWAYS NICE.
I DROVE THE FAMILY MONDAY
MORNING TO THE AIRPORT IN
BOZEMAN, APPROACHING AN
INTERSECTION 2 MILES FROM THE
AIRPORT I HIT A PATCH OF ICE AND
I COULD NOT STOP OUR SUV.
WE SLID INTO THE INTERSECTION OF
A BUSY ROAD AND INTO THE PATH OF
A BIG PICKUP TRUCK WHICH SLAMMED
INTO A DRIVER SIDE DOOR.
WE CAREENED INTO A DITCH AND
FLIPPED SIDEWAYS AND I STARTED
TO TRY TO PUSH OPEN THE
PASSENGER DOOR.
A MAN HELD OPEN THE DOOR SO WE
COULD CLIMB OUT.
HE STOPPED TO HELP US, WE
CLIMBED OUT, THE DRIVER OF THE
PICKUP TRUCK HAD CALLED THE
POLICE AND WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
OUR FAMILY FIRST AND FOREMOST.
MONTANA HIGHWAY PATROL QUICKLY
ARRIVED, EMS, PARAMEDICS ARRIVED
QUICKLY TOO AND WE ESCAPED WITH
MINOR INJURIES.
A CONCUSSION, 14 STITCHES ON A
CHIN, AND A LOOSE TOOTH.
IF THANK YOU HIGHWAY PATROL AND
EMS PERSONNEL WHO WERE ALL
AMAZING.
AS WE WERE RELEASED FROM THE
HOSPITAL, I TWEETED THIS.
DON'T TAKE ANYTHING FOR GRANTED,
EVERY DAY IS A BLESSING.
FAMILY IS EVERYTHING.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO REMIND
YOURSELF OF THAT BEFORE